[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
really excited to be talking to you guys
about deep platforming in follower
counts this is a pressing topic that's
going on right now across the online
internet sphere Who am I what a
simulation for those that are new
simulation is a thought provoking
multidisciplinary show that features
some of the greatest minds of our time
in long-form nuance driven conversation
you can find all these different
interviews on our Channel and also I
care a lot about maximizing
civilizational prosperity that's my
thing taking out all of the structural
violence --is that are going on within
our frameworks and resource flows to
enable people to be their best
so that's who I am that's what we are
for all you newbies alright let's talk
about this deep platforming and follow
our counts I have a really cool notes to
show you guys all right so one of the
things that comes to mind initially is
algorithms seems to be like the most
pressing thing is knowing who is
deciding on the code that is making the
decisions so for example how does one
even get discovered how does a video get
discovered how does an how does a how
does Instagram decide who to put in the
feed for the individual that's viewing
the feed and how do these things
actually work when you like it or
commented do they stay more frequently
in your feed etc and so how do these
things work and why are we not being
extremely transparent with them well
more so than anything else the sort of
the the way that we behave with these
internet protocols should be transparent
so that we know how the algorithms work
we know how we behave with them we know
how to align them in tweak
tune them so that we can do things like
we'll talk about at the end enable us to
find more aspiring artists and
entrepreneurs around the world and help
them maximize to their fullest potential
so so what are these algorithms in all
of their nuance and all of their
complexity and who even gets to decide
on who you know the different platforms
right now the YouTube Facebook Twitter
patreon etc that's deciding who to give
their platform to or not who's being
deep platformed in all of these on all
across all these platforms is extremely
interesting and important because a lot
of the times I'll talk about this in a
moment these sometimes conspiracy
theorists like [ __ ] Copernicus again
most people don't realize that
Copernicus was against 99.9% of people
saying that the earth is not the center
of the universe and that the Earth
orbits the star and the star does an
orbit earth and so again it's things
like this that sometimes conspiracy
theorists are right I'll get to that in
more detail but who is to say that we
get to choose to ban certain people from
our platform or not and there are some
publicly like we'll talk about this in a
moment but these sort of biases that
occur for who - who - deep platform the
the biases that occur to see to express
what shows up in people's feeds there's
algorithms that parse videos before they
go up and that they say that this video
is gonna be demonetised things like that
all right so let's give these examples
of like it's a really hard job right
I'll explain why it's a really hard job
so sometimes people will literally post
videos to the Internet of them chopping
someone else's head off across the world
so when things like that happen
yeah okay that makes a lot of sense it's
hard as a content delivery network as a
social platform that you have to make
sure that oh my god like okay well we
don't want kids to see it as potentially
okay to chop other people's heads off
but at the same time it's important for
people to know that that's going on
around the world so we can globally move
forward and try and fix that issue so
how do you decide on which one of those
is okay and how much of
to actually allow and where to allow it
how to move and organize this and maybe
that's what certain organizations are
for is to go and eradicate those issues
in order for other people to potentially
not be dramatically impacted by them and
there are tons of other examples like
this here's another one that I have
someone publicly expresses their
suicidal thoughts and we send them help
but if the videos deemed unsafe for
others to watch how can we learn from
this experience best so take an example
like someone's literally going and
saying that you know I'm I'm hurting I
you know I want to hurt myself and if we
don't let that video go on the internet
then we don't even know that that's
happening potentially someone could go
and help them without that video going
on the internet and maybe that's right
but what if someone else is feeling that
way and then they go and hurt themselves
because they've never seen anyone else
talk about it so there's all this
different nuance and variability to
unpack when it comes to knowing which
videos to actually display on the
internet versus which ones to take off
and what are the reasons for what are we
learning from these processes and how
can we again learn from the sort of
experiences the best possible way so ok
now on to Copernicus I love this segment
here because conspiracy theorists are
actually occasionally right there is a
lot of pressure from greed and
corruption to shut down conspiracy
theorists because they don't want us to
know the truth and so when you have
conspiracy theorists that that say that
over and over again something and they
try and program it into culture even
though it might be wrong that that can
be harmful it can be harmful when
they're going off and maybe 99% of the
things they say are wrong that can be
kind of harmful at times because if only
1% of the time they're right is it that
worth it it's crazy to even try and
calculate that now if you take into
account conspiracy theorists that maybe
only speaks when they are I've done a
tremendous amount of research on
something and that they can say
something with an extreme level of
confidence and they're right more often
then they can gain credibility but what
if these platforms are shutting down
these theorists so that's extremely
makes
me you know makes me makes me hesitate
because it's like we're giving but these
are the platforms that give people
voices and that they need to be heard
because there's so many pressing things
going on in the world so many variables
people don't like being called out on
their [ __ ] people don't like being
called out on their greed or their
corruption or what their malevolence and
their violence so that when people get
called out on that they get hurt and
that's not that's not that's that's not
okay to shut down people that are
calling them out on those things so
alright decentralization may help in all
of this so how do we move forward with
properly figuring out how to give
platforms to things that may scare us or
may make us feel uncomfortable or may
challenge the government how do we give
these platforms how do we give them
these platforms that enable and bespeak
to make civilization better even though
they may challenge some of the
authoritarian states there is so much
Big Brother esque stuff going on right
now it's so scary in many ways the
authoritarian States is everything gonna
be completely transparent and oversight
who knows what's gonna be the best
solution it does not seem like that's a
best solution it seems like some sort of
peace and prosperity and a total
collective progress is the best we don't
know how to get there yet but I love
talking about figuring out how to get
there and so again super important to
figure out how to give voices to people
that are trying to figure out how to
maximize the potential of truth in the
world and the potential of collective
coherence here all right on we go to
who's real and who's not these bots
these are very very crazy follower
counts are a lot like bank accounts
being published on people's t-shirts so
that's an interesting analogy and I find
it to be somewhat true that it's
important for a couple of reasons
because when you land on someone's page
and you see that they have a certain
amount of followers a that means that
they have at least been around for a
certain amount of time they've at least
built up an audience somehow so people
actually do in fact see that they've
done some sort of work on their account
they've done some sort of work in
bringing value to other people that's
why they've built up their followership
but how many of their followers are
actually real followers versus bots and
how do we even make the right algorithms
to go and parse and figure out how many
are bots and how many are not and how do
we eradicate BOTS do we eradicate BOTS
what are BOTS even doing on the internet
etc soon we're gonna have we already
have social Android so what about when
you see social Androids walking around
on the streets how do you figure out if
they're real if they're human or if
they're a robot what does that even mean
this is coming in the next couple of
decades so we have to be extremely
extremely vigilant about how to best
ethically move forward on these things
so you can tell when someone's worked
hard on their profile and brought lots
of people value but at the same time you
know how many of those users are
actually real users all right and then
YouTube for example this is kind of
interesting YouTube lets you actually
hide your subscriber counts which is
interesting Twitter doesn't allow you
Instagram doesn't allow you at cetera so
it's interesting to see what's gonna
happen with with that idea is what would
happen if we hit a subscriber counts
because it definitely and follower
counts because it definitely affects the
psychology and I'll explain this in a
moment you want to know how popular
people are but you don't want it to bias
you so for example let's let's take a
look at this if you see a post that has
only one reach retweet versus 100
retweets would you say that you were
psychologically more you have a higher
tendency to want to retweet when there's
more retweets or like when there's more
likes or comment there's more comments
well the idea is yes or watch a video
and there's more views and so now what
happens when you are you know when the
numbers aren't shown well what if the
what if the retweet count or the light
count or the subscriber count cetera is
not shown of the view counts not shown
you know how many more people are more
likely to watch that video this gets
really nuanced and difficult to figure
out so I want to come full circle on
these concepts let's come full circle
with our screen so how do we make it so
that more people can publish content
questioning the current paradigms and
inquiring for truth obviously it's
extremely important to make sure that
people are not were not amplifying
malevolence and badness on the internet
but that we're giving continued
to give a voice to people that are in
the Copernicus realm that are seeking
truth how do the major platforms decide
who to show in recommended feeds with
what agenda and bias is going on in
these algorithms and how can we be
transparent with these algorithms and
we're about to be with more push for
decentralization which is exciting
because I would like to know how to make
it so that young artists and
entrepreneurs that should be getting
discovered actually get discovered in
Africa and South America and Asia and
Europe and us everywhere across the
world how do we actually get the young
and aspirational and super smart
entrepreneurs and artists discovered how
can we make our algorithms focus on cool
things like that or how do we make our
algorithms focus on people that need the
mental health assistance how do we make
our algorithms focus on the things that
make us more human that get us to more
in person I - I scenarios with people
that that we find that can maximize our
potential and flourishing in the world
and how do our biases change when we see
followers sub like counts so this has
been a session with you and I on the
subject of deep platforming follower and
flaw follower counts it's been a lot of
fun everyone
I appreciate you tuning in there's a lot
of nuance and multi variability here and
it's important for us to actually talk
about what the transition is going to be
in the next couple of years with social
media it's a big land grab Gary Vee
talks about it like a land grab I love
that way of phrasing it there's a huge
land grab it's like the gold rush right
now for the attention economy is going
on the attention economy Gold Rush
that's an interesting one I've heard it
put that way before and so that's what's
going on so the more and more people are
going and trying to grab people's
attention and stuff so that's this is
extremely important knowing how to work
with follower counts and how the issues
like the platforming are going on
finding those copernicus people these
great artists entrepreneurs thanks
everyone for tuning in I greatly
appreciate you much love much love give
us your thoughts in the comments below
on what you think are the best solutions
moving forward also give us your
thoughts with just how you
can execute your future and build the
future and manifest your destiny into
the world join our public telegram and
talk to us about it talk to us about
these nuance driven conversations these
thought-provoking questions we talk
about it all the time in that chat also
yeah
tune in more and much love to you all
and we will see you soon go and have
these top-earning questions with other
people much love much love and
[Music]